well the latest Twitter files dump which
is apparently the 10th if we're counting
reveals efforts from both the Biden and
Trump white houses to suppress ideas on
social media related to covet 19.
according to Independent journalist
David zweig quote Twitter did suppress
views many from doctors and scientific
experts that conflicted with the
official positions of the White House
adding dissident yet legitimate content
was labeled as misinformation in the
accounts of doctors and others were
suspended here to react is Fox News
medical contributor and Dr Mark Siegel
Dr Siegel what do you make what is your
reaction to this quite lengthy uh
Twitter files dump showing that both the
Trump and the bite Administration sought
to have some moderate content moderation
very disturbing uh censorship especially
coming from the government Griff is on
the road to totalitarianism isn't it on
either side anyone in power trying to
suppress opinions and Science is based
on the diversity of opinions especially
in a situation of evolving science with
a new virus that people don't understand
don't know about yet that's why the word
emergency use authorization was used
because it was new because the vaccine
was new because we didn't know how
contagious and deadly and if how much
this virus affected us I said at the
very beginning of the pandemic I was
concerned about lockdowns because I had
researched that for prior books on prior
lockdowns going all the way back to the
Middle Ages where there were problems
with them because people rebelled people
were fearful and they didn't necessarily
contain the pathogen and this virus we
soon found out was way more contagious
than we thought so lockdowns were a poor
strategy and yet there was an attempt
made to call that misinformation and
disinformation and by the way once you
started with the term misinformation the
term mandate soon followed right because
if only your way is right you have to
impose it you have to superimpose it and
they were superimposing that the
government was on things that are
questionable now you probably know that
I believe in this vaccine but I'll tell
you something else about it though it's
not the kind of vaccine that prevents
spread consistently it is not surprising
that that soon went off the table and it
became more targeted towards severity
and if you're not preventing spread with
the vaccine how can you mandate its use
that was a problem and again anyone who
said that was marginalized on Twitter or
attacked on Twitter which is supposed to
be a public forum hey Dr Siegel so what
we found in this dump that spans both
administrations because you talk about
misinformation it's important to sort of
point out what David zweig found in the
case of the Trump Administration it was
that they were meeting with Twitter
Executives saying hey we're worried
about misinformation like this tweet
where we saw people falsely sitting
there was a run on grocery stores they
didn't want the Panic to happen but then
when the Biden Administration came in
they were focusing more on the
anti-vaxxers here is an example that the
that's what I posted here this is an
email regarding Harvard's Dr koldorf's
tweet about vaccines for everyone saying
this hi team sitting a heads up that we
will have to take action on Martin
coldor if a professor of Harvard Medical
School for violating our coveted 19
misinformation policy specifically by
sharing false information regarding the
efficacy of the covid-19 vaccines which
goes against CDC guidelines so just one
example Dr Siegel but how much do you
believe this may have impacted the
outcome of where we are today
two points on this grip first of all I
don't think you can on the Trump
Administration I don't think you can
control Panic by by controlling
information I don't agree with that but
to be fair I found that Administration
to be open to my ideas even when I
interviewed president Trump he said
you're the first to point out collateral
damage from the lockdowns so but I don't
agree with controlling uh information on
to suppress Panic your cause you cause
Panic by doing that second on Dr caldorf
I don't actually agree completely with
his statements on how he feels the
vaccine works but you know what I do
believe in his right to say so his right
to say so on Twitter and anywhere else
he wants that's the that's the debate
I'm talking about it's got to be open I
get I get to say My Views he gets to say
his views very disturbing that anyone
would Target him and try to marginalize
him or or cancel him out such such a
great Point Dr Mark Siegel will see what
comes in the New Year we know hearings
are coming perhaps this will be part of
that Dr Mark Siegel thank you very much
have a good Tuesday I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis